okay hello and welcome to our webinar
today and we are here today to discuss
the AI act and in particular general
purpose AI so how can we think about
mitigating harms and AI framework well
risks can emerge in the AI systems um
during design development and uh
deployment and there on through the AI
lifecycle so we think that uh risks kind
of mitigating these risks and harms
involves clearly designating
responsibility and for us there's three
layers to this some requirements only
the provider can do
um some that should be done uh by the
the user and some that should be done by
both provider and user how do we Define
general purpose AI systems and there's
been a lot of discussion that everything
is a general purpose AI system
um and I really want to push back on
that here in this panel
um we've written a paper where we've
defined general purpose AI systems as AI
systems that can accomplish or be
adapted to accomplish a range of
distinct tasks including some for which
they weren't intentionally trained I
think that we need to be very careful
about the definition because this
definition would not include recommender
systems it would not include voice
assistance and many of the the other
systems that some have suggested would
also fall under this heading we want the
rules to be applied for everyone and we
need to look at how in this specific
case we can ensure that there is
the correct allocation of responsibility
a really good understanding of the value
chain and a good understanding on who
can do what in this in this chain which
in general purpose of course gets a bit
more complex because you do not only
have one provider but you may have then
several providers down the line who have
to cooperate in one way or another and
the second thing is of course they're
how to organize this cooperation between
these providers although some colleagues
favor an exception for the use of the
open source I and my group we are a bit
more cautious the principle we are
trying to avoid is that those who
release this type of Technology are
exempt from
um responsibility and also liability for
any damages resulting from Downstream
use the effects or which are also due to
the Upstream design there is no doubt
about the value of the open source but
shifting all the obligations into the
smes because this is what I think would
happen is not in my opinion a good
choice you have to make sure that must
be our purpose we want to have this
balance between Innovation and
trustworthiness but we must as well make
sure that every high-risk system
delivers the same provides the same
level of of trust and stability and
robustness and accuracy and that cannot
depend on the way it has been developed
if we think about it uh Dali which is
open AI is large-scale image generation
model the first version of not only came
out in January 2021 and It produced
little 250 or 260 pixel by 260 pixel
images uh which you know only goes so
far and yet a year later it was
producing kind of large high quality
images
um and and considerably more
feature-range and considerably more
impactful so we're seeing significant
progress in in in in the performance of
more generalized models and we're also
seeing a really rapid productization
right I do think that some of the
requirements in the AI act can't be made
to apply in full to general purpose AI
systems think human oversight is a
really good example of that where it's
really hard to ensure human oversight if
if the company doesn't know the exact
use case in which a downstream provider
might use the system it's not
necessarily a huge ask to have providers
comply with with a set or many of the
high risk requirements
um it was a China Bryson who uh kind of
described even the full set of
obligations uh is pretty lightweight um
in places
um I there's a kind of essentially
mainly compelling due diligence via
self-assessment by the companies
themselves that's what's kind of
expected to occur in roughly 90 of use
cases
um possibility of third-party checks by
regulatory authorities are there but
would come further down the line
um so so also to remember the size of
what we're asking in this isn't isn't
necessarily unusable but then also to
Mark's point about kind of where those
responsibilities sit
um and and that is where there will be
need to be some kind of somewhat of a
special regime I think needed uh for
General uh purpose AI